and I want to welcome to this video
playing pala yoga's from Australia all
right and yeah Sicilian we can tell the
dragon I've looked at this for ages and
this is the modern mainline yeah this is
not so good but it's a different matter
how to play against it is six 94 94 at
some point I don't know if it is here
taking the exchange is not a good idea
it actually leads to a very good game
for glycan it's but around here I'm and
basically um yeah out of book out of
book quite oh let's the shirt says
something technical and that bishop no
just goes back yeah I can probably take
and put it here shouldn't be so bad
strategically speaking but now this is
not how it is usually played a thing
interesting
interestingly I still said washing
machines were bit annoying with the
sounds hmm yeah but who did I mean he
cannot play
I mean his head was hanging which she
does not really want to defend probably
have probably he does not need him okay
but if he takes a couple of times only
one I don't mind that so much I'm trying
to weaken his position here on the on
the kingside I didn't really see any
good alternative here to me keeping the
tension maybe he just plays um something
like Queen to d7 here
[Music]
no I didn't like that
well we have very aggressive way of
dealing with this what to do probably
taking ones or not I don't know
this could be an ideas Julie what is he
doing the f4 I can take the five then
this week it is king Satya enormously
but you might have something why start
working 9595 take c3 I don't understand
maybe he just plays he takes and place
the exchange down it could be if that
could be a compensation really and that
can be compensation but what what else
did bishop the truth is that even I got
who I get the square I get the square on
the phone maybe I mean it is a temple in
a way on the on the rook
he might okay he can try to keep it I
mean keep it on d5 I don't necessarily
need to take it by the way I can also go
94 if I manage like 94 and Bishop knew
fair so and then everything is fine okay
so this is such a situation I don't take
this but go night for rather keep
everything in in check it's a fantastic
piece they are only four and this Bishop
sucks the thing is I still have to get
rid of this active is active
configuration on the D file yeah this is
certainly making some sense but if I
play here is there some tactic that
kills me or what what's happening there
I don't see a tactic
and if he has to go back that didn't
help
okay well Bishop c3 is not not on
anymore on a 96 years to play almost no
matter what and I cannot maybe maybe
King c2 and we should see one but he's
got to create five the whole time that
is a that's annoying anyway I can go see
for Bishop c3 but I don't know how good
that is
she was also hanging so it's not all
that great
okay I go here prepared King b1 bishop
c1 and Quincy for in some cases
you
yeah here and I don't know if that just
as much I can go here we'll just take it
here just take take and see for yeah
that's the thing if you if he has a for
light when I'm in trouble if it doesn't
I'm Wallace winning taken I don't know
don't have enough time shouldn't have
gotten into this time pressure here in
this game okay
there won't get many difficult decisions
around him
so we need to take now homework
blundering into some silly tactic which
is really possible and some certainly
some tricks in this position
again I'm not falling to some tactic in
the next one or tools this is more less
winning yeah this is this is a move this
is really a move shoot f3 is hanging at
91 come on I remember I know this is a
tough move to do to answer en this time
good time here crap at this simple you
just can take come on this is crazy I'm
losing this game I was basically a piece
up with this crap Bishop on g7 yeah it's
unbelievable William okay really
unbelievable check ma'am check and it's
bishop you actually killing me okay
add to frustratingly play oh man this is
just just restraining this is a position
where you just don't have to run into
such a move like 23 and you win but okay
it happens it can certainly happen okay
maybe like I mean the computer says the
leg is okay which is possible I mean he
is basically a piece down on g7 but he's
got some active pieces and it's
difficult to play an ITF - we already
had yeah still I don't believe in this
story I mean I mean there was always to
win material but I couldn't I mean
taking taking this is so example giving
like really good player I mean this is
not something that you want to do 94 is
just stronger
now you can take now I wasn't sure I
mean I can take and play this but he's
got rooked e 4 B 3 E 4 is saw that and
this is not clear
I mean Queen e5 there are tons of moves
okay
so surprised that blacks should be okay
Everett okay whoever says that this game
has had some logic M he plays the piece
down on b7 and that doesn't matter I
have no way to consolidate this position
and win or like B clearly better I mean
you will any endgame here for example
simply any ending but there may be there
is no nothing to do here
Queen B 395 why it's just okay when the
Y is just Y is just vice is slightly
better for white I don't understand this
I mean this is a this is just clearly
better for what
what is the engine doing here I don't
understand it
what does he manage you for years for we
with some miracle moves he placed before
immediately and regains it somehow okay
but otherwise this is just terrible
[Music]
okay so you can play for somehow yeah
maybe I mean I'm not so I'm not well
coordinated that's certainly true okay
you need all kinds of tactics to make
this work at the first place but the
others didn't work you tonight F 2 and T
M 23 I hear it's really tough to play
but I still does this lost I didn't see
you not see one a single of course I
actually have more time here still
so I could do I could play this him and
this was some kind of draw heads across
a game losing against mm now Kaiba the
position was not as good for white as I
was thinking I was really thinking that
this is completely bad him and and this
is not unreasonable to think I mean
again this is not playing at all so
probably what did I do a plate c3 so
with hindsight maybe this isn't a good
idea I mean what happens if I play this
Bishop c1 and I mean I don't believe it
that cannot be
that cannot be okay for black this
position it's just not possible
[Music]
yeah but sorry I don't understand this
why is this equal why is the engine
assessing this position is equal midas
better in any minor piece ending maybe i
don't get to any minor piece ending i
don't know i understand he's got to
develop completely understand but still
it seems she always gets before in
somehow and yeah very strange civil okay
guys thanks for watching